trotz geltender kontakt beschränkungen
haben sich am samstag in berlin wieder
mehrere hundert menschen versammelt sie
demonstrierten gegen eine einschränkung
von grundrechten in der korona krise die
polizei forderte die teilnehmer über
lautsprecher auf die unerlaubte
demonstrationen zu verlassen
[Musik]
die meisten sind dem aufruf gefolgt
vereinzelt griff die polizei zu
freiheits beschränkenden maßnahmen rund
100 kräfte waren im einsatz
wie an den wochenenden zuvor hatten sich
die demonstranten an der volksbühne im
bezirk mitte versammelt nach der
aktuellen verordnung zur eindämmung des
corona virus sind in berlin nur
versammlungen unter freiem himmel von
maximal 20 menschen erlaubt